les titres de votre journal c'est fait
on peut désormais se rendre à pied sec
de france en angleterre et vice versa
baghdad répond positivement à l'offre de
dialogue lancé hier par les américains
demain soir sur antenne de l'interview
exclusive de saddam hussein nouvelle
crise au tchad hissène habré a fui le
pays et les rebelles sont entrés dans
n'djamena les européens sous la
protection des soldats français
l'un des plus vieux acteurs français des
meilleurs acteurs français de ce siècle
pierre dux est mort à l'âge de 82 ans
madame monsieur bonsoir le rêve de jules
césar de napoléon et de bien d'autres
et enfin exaucé l'angleterre n'est plus
une île depuis 12h12 très exactement
depuis la poignée de main historique
échangé à 100 mètres sous le niveau de
la mer par deux ouvriers du chantier
reportage de notre envoyé spécial
patrick esther
à mi chemin entre la grande bretagne et
la france deux marteaux piqueurs attaque
les 30 derniers centimètres de craie
bleue une page d'histoire se déchirent
philippe cozette et robert graham fagg
échange une bonne poignée de main
l'angleterre n'est désormais plus une
île on peut y aller à pied ou du moins
s'y faufiler dans le courant d'air qui
circulent
les drapeaux sont hissés un vent violent
créé par les différences de pression
atmosphérique entre folkestone et cas
les échanges de cadeaux
et lorsque les paroles comment sera posé
quelques problèmes linguistiques place
au champagne universel mais comment ne
pas avoir une petite pensée nostalgique
pour robin
le tunnelier anglais qui va être
abandonnée sur place
1200 tonnes enterré et bétonner à jamais
sur le bord du tunnel il est vrai que le
sort de brigitte la machine française
n'est pas plus enviable
elle a été découpé au chalumeau pour
récupérer la ferraille
seuls les moteurs électriques seront
épargnés les anglais ça s'est bien passé
nous étions nous étions des concurrents
ça a été ça a été une course avec eux
nous les avons battues quelques fois ils
nous ont repris un peu nos records enfin
on est on est quand même en se tient on
se tient la main dans la main entre
temps quelques britanniques sont montés
dans une première brésil
direction la france premier véritable
voyage
ça va peut-être pas à l'arrivée en gare
de la ciotat mais c'est quand même pas
mal pour l'arrivée de ce train là en
tout cas
quelques chiffres pour re situer
l'importance de cet exploit et c'en est
un 50 km au total ont été percés
nécessitant l'évacuation de 10 millions
de mètres cube de craie soit
l'équivalent de trois pyramides de
khéops coût total estimé à ce jour 76
milliards de francs tout absolument tout
a été prévu en matière de sécurité
720000 arc de béton de 8 tonnes habits
l'intérieur de ce tunnel prévu pour
résister aux séismes les plus violents
les techniciens ont même prévu des
pièges électrique pour tuer raso renard
venus du continent depuis toujours en
effet l'angleterre seul pays européen
épargné par la rage redoutent ce virus
reportage côté britannique avec notre
correspondant christian mary mono
philippe agréable deux tunneliers ils se
serrent la main dans le tunnel pour la
première fois le maire de folkestone se
réjouit de cette rencontre historique
c'est vraiment pour notre région une
occasion à saisir
nous ne devons pas rester dans l'ombre
c'est aux gens du kent maintenant d'agir
températures hivernales ou des intérêts
le public anglais n'étaient pas très
nombreux
il a boudé la manifestation enfin le
train ribes et douaniers et s'auto
visibles comme érection satisfaite du
ministre des transports
il fait un petit effort no wonder même
chose avec son homologue anglais c'est
un peu mieux et plus explicite
ce soit très populaire venait du jour
perdu dans la foule sous notre cause est
le taulier de calais échange de cadeaux
un morceau de craie et côté français une
médaille de la part de l'anglais ce
formidable comme un croisé puis je veux
veux rencontrer sous d'avancé puis 2-3
et puis de rencontrer chacun d'autres
cette fois le passage à la douane
n'aurait été qu'une formalité voir un
plaisir plus tard il ne sort pas de même
le train siffle trois fois pour le
prochain il faudra attendre 1993
je vous le disais je césar déjà rêvé de
ce tunnel sous la manche
en fait le premier projet sérieux date
de 1800 de un ingénieur français albert
mathieu avait en effet soumis à
bonaparte un projet de passage de routes
pavées éclairé par des bugs à huile
rappel nostalgique signé jacques violée
en deux siècles une bonne centaine de
projets plus ou moins farfelues et
fantaisiste sorti de l'imagination
d'ingénieurs et de financiers le plus
extravagant traversée en calèche dans un
tunnel éclairée aux flambeaux de grandes
cheminées au dessus de la mer permettant
de respirer dès 1790 un tunnel pour
envahir l'angleterre pendant qu'une
armada de navires et de montgolfières
attaque sur mer et dans les airs les
troupes à pied et les chevaux traverse
dans un tunnel sous le pas de calais la
bataille de trafalgar mettra un terme à
ses rêves d'invasion autre projet sous
sous sous un sous marin sur voie ferrée
l'ingénieur français thomé de gamond va
consacrer 30 ans de sa vie à différents
projets en 1850
il propose le plus sérieux d'entre tous
napoléon iii et la reine victoria sont
d'accord malheureusement l'état major
britannique fait tout capoter les
militaires estiment que la sécurité
nationale ne pourra plus être assuré en
1881 c'est plus sérieux
un protocole est signé un kilomètre et
nuit de galeries fut même creusé mais
les militaires toujours se reparle du
péril de l'invasion et l'on enterre les
projets pendant près d'un siècle en 1966
messieurs pompidou et wilson reparle de
tunnels
on signe on creuse mais on s'arrête à
nouveau en 1975 il faudra attendre
janvier 86 pour prendre enfin mon départ
le président mitterrand signe avec la
dame de fer
madame thatcher qui à quelques jours
près on aurait pu assister à la
cérémonie de ce matin mais désire est
elle vraiment voir l'angleterre
s'attacher définitivement à l'europe la
crise du golfe saddam hussein a répondu
dès ce matin positivement à l'offre de
dialogue lancé hier par le président
bush
dans son communiqué le président irakien
fait à nouveau référence à son
initiative du 12 août qui proposait un
règlement global de tous les conflits
dans la région à commencer par
l'évacuation des territoires occupés par
israël
le point avec dorothée olliéric saddam
hussein présidé la prière avant
l'ouverture de la session extraordinaire
du conseil de la révolution
un conseil si entériner l'offre de
dialogue de george bush le président
saddam hussein est donc prêt à recevoir
à bagdad le secrétaire d'état américain
james baker pour un dialogue sérieux et
approfondi toutefois il a précisé que ce
dialogue devrait s'accompagner de
discussion élargie à tous les conflits
du proche orient et notamment la
question palestinienne
à bagdad pourtant plusieurs milliers
d'irakiens ont manifesté aujourd'hui
pour protester contre la résolution 678
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu une
résolution qui autorise le recours à la
force contre bagdad
les manifestants principalement des
jeunes et des étudiants ont scandé des
slogans hostiles aux états unis
non à la présence américaine dans le
golfe l'irak résistera un petit rien
pour les états unis le dialogue
américano irakien devrait déboucher
obligatoirement sur un retrait sans
condition du koweït par les troupes de
bagdad
il semble quand même ce soir que la
logique de guerre a cédé la place à une
logique de dialogue antenne 2 et france
inter diffusera demain vers 19h
l'interview exclusive de saddam hussein
ont recueilli cet après midi à bagdad
par christine ockrent et ivan levaï
déclarations particulièrement
intéressante
au lendemain de cette offre de dialogue
faite par george bush et à 45 jours de
l'ultimatum lancé par l'onu
la proposition surprise de george bush a
reçu un accueil favorable dans
pratiquement toutes les capitales du
monde
signe qui ne trompe pas les cours de
pétrole ont immédiatement accusé une
chute alors que wall street enregistré
au contraire une forte hausse à
washington les principaux responsables
du congrès du parlement
inquiet des perspectives guerrière ont
vigoureusement appuyer leur président
commentaire de notre correspondant
jacquat bouchard entre george bush et
l'ailleurs du congrès qui l'a reçu à la
maison blanche s'est de nouveau la lune
de miel tous démocrates comme
républicains ont approuvé l'initiative
présidentielle d'un dialogue direct avec
bagdad
deux des chefs de file de l'opposition
démocrates l'ont déclaré sans ambiguïté
après la réunion
c'est une kim chance donnée à la paix ne
doit pourtant pas masquer l'essentiel
monsieur bush accepte de discuter pas de
négocier avec l'irak
les oiseaux le putting spa de ce qu'eric
my way
la résolution de jeudi la 13e adoptée
par le conseil de sécurité dit
clairement à saddam hussein
le temps presse vous devez quitter le
koweït la méthode choisie par le
président américain n'est pas dénuée de
risques ans attend ici à d'émana
de la part de l'irak par exemple pour
lier le dénouement de la crise du golfe
à la question palestinienne
cette méthode présente cependant
l'immense avantage de rassurer l'opinion
américaine qui approuve le déploiement
militaire qui soutient la politique des
sanctions mais qui rejette
majoritairement l'idée d'un recours à la
force dans l'immédiat hier après midi le
président américain a pris tout le monde
à contre-pied à leurs questions genre ce
bague cette fameuse logique de guerre
at-elle pris du plomb dans l aile je ne
serai pas à catégorique cependant il est
évident que dès l'instant où l'on
commence à discuter quel que soit le
thème de la discussion la logique de
guerre est mise entre parenthèses sans
pour autant entrer dans une logique de
paix la proposition du président bush
est elle un véritable coup de théâtre ou
l'aboutissement d'une stratégie alors
que ses positions paraissait très ferme
et inflexible j'estime pour ma part que
nous arrivons à la fin d'une stratégie
qui dès le départ avait pour but de
faire fléchir le président irakien
saddam hussein aujourd'hui la position
américaine est forte sur le plan
militaire
contrairement au 2 août date de
l'invasion l'armée américaine par est
opérationnel elle maintient sa pression
puisque la semaine prochaine il est
prévu d'envoyer encore 300 avions de
combat supplémentaires
deuxièmement la dernière solution
résolution des nations unies autorisant
à partir du 15 janvier le recours à la
force donne entièrement satisfaction aux
états unis avec ses atouts monsieur bush
maintenant peut dire essayons une
dernière tentative pour sortir de la
crise avant d'en arriver à la guerre en
quelque sorte la pression psychologique
a été pesant au cours de ses quatre mois
voyons s'il a une chance de donner des
résultats autre information cet
après-midi le faisan mitterrand a eu au
téléphone son homologue américain en
effet le président bush aurait selon
certains étaient très sensibles aux
analyses du président mitterrand le
président bush plus que ses conseillers
qui était pour une action militaire
immédiate et déjà depuis jeudi la france
avaient été consultés sur cette
initiative reste évidemment à savoir sur
quoi le dialogue va s'engager
la position des états unis et des
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité dont la france est toujours la
même
pas de prime à l'agresseur quitté
d'abord le koweït et après nous
pourrions examiner les autres problèmes
du proche orient
ocha de déroute militaire pour les
forces gouvernementales les premiers
rebelles ont pénétré en milieu
d'après-midi dans la capitale djamena
deux avions devraient arriver dans
quelques heures pour procéder à
l'évacuation des européens présents sur
place à commencer par les français
le président hissène habré ses proches
ont fui leur pays pour le cameroun à la
têt du chat depuis sept ans maintenant
hissène habré avait accédé au pouvoir en
renversant vokoun hayden alors président
du gouvernement d'union nationale
autrement dit la boucle est bouclée
jérôme baugnies dernière image d'hissène
habré à l'aéroport de n'djamena il ya
quatre jours recevant le premier
ministre ougandais aujourd'hui il est en
fuite
au cameroun le renard du tibesti a
trouvé son maître en la personne
d'idriss deby son ancien chef d'état
major
après la chute hier du verrou d'abéché
il célèbre et savait qu'il avait perdue
et que la route était libre pour les
forces rebelles vers la capitale qui
vient de tomber son coup férir léon 150
soldats français de l'opération épervier
n'interviennent pas dans le conflit se
contentant d'assurer la sécurité des
étrangers dans les rues de n'djamena
livré au billard ils ne sont pas occupés
l'ambassadeur a demandé que tous les
gens évacués
ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'intérêt au
tchad qui sont et conquérant pour ça se
comprend ils sont bons ils vont à la
base ceux qui ont les familles ceux qui
ont des enfants en bas âge je comptais
ça commence à les inquiéter et fond mais
alors ces gens ont laissé leurs maisons
bon ben
c'est facile de rentrer puis de prendre
pour tous les gens comme nous qui sommes
restés et quand second temps en temps à
l'extérieur parce que faut quand même
sans fermer un petit peu pour fait pour
pas les faire rentrer mais lorsqu'on se
montre que nous sommes là tous ah bon
bah ils viennent pas mais croyez-moi il
nous faut il nous faut tenir encore
cette nuit quoi ceux qui effectuent tard
c'est cela un dispositif aérien vient
d'être mise en place pour rapatrier les
français qui veulent quitter une djamena
où le chef des rebelles doit pas rater
dans deux jours un numéro de téléphone
est mis à la disposition des familles
par le ministère des affaires étrangères
le 1 pour paris 45 50 34 60
pour le ministre de la coopération
jacques pelletier la situation est calme
au tchad et nos compatriotes ne risque
absolument rien environ 400 militaires
français sont actuellement sur place
pour veiller à leur sécurité et le
ministre de la défense jean pierre
chevènement a annoncé tout à l'heure un
renforcement de notre présence militaire
là-bas je délire que nous avons appris
ce matin
à notre grande surprise que le président
hissène habré avait trouvé refuge au
cameroun est un pays voisin du tchad
à partir de là la seule autorité légale
aux termes de la constitution tchadienne
et le président de l'assemblée nationale
monsieur jean alingué boys
il a lancé un appel au calme nous
espérons qu'il sera entendu nous pensons
qu'il faut que les tchadiens
resserrent leur solidarité il faut que
le calme revienne nous avons pris les
dispositions pour cela et en particulier
pour assurer la protection de nos
ressortissants une compagnie de
parachutistes de calvi doit se mettre en
route pour une djamena et nous prévoyons
également d'y faire venir d'autres
forces
mais ces forces-là n'interviendront pas
dans les combats entre tchadiens
non ce n'est pas leur rôle je voulais
dit leur rôle est limité à la protection
de nos ressortissants qui sont environ
2000 journée historique une de plus
demain en allemagne avec les premières
élections libres dans l'ensemble du pays
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des nazis en
33 l'actuel chancelier helmut kohl le
grand artisan de cette unité allemande
par très largement favori pour se
succéder à lui-même son challenger le
socialiste oskar lafontaine a tenté de
convaincre ses concitoyens que cette
unification allait leur coûter fort cher
mais apparemment l'argument n'a guère
porté reportage de notre correspondant
philippe rochot quand le train de ce car
la fontaine arrive dans les cités
d'allemagne de l'est
il n'y a pas grand monde pour
l'accueillir lafontaine candidat du
parti socialiste le spd est un perdant
et il le dit il fait campagne ici au fin
fond de l'ancienne rda à beulen dont la
seule originalité et d'être jumelée avec
vous en veulent à étrangement oskar
lafontaine plaide pour une augmentation
des impôts ce qui n'est guère populaire
c'est le seul moyen dit-il de financiers
l'unité allemande
car il faudra combler un déficit de 400
milliards de francs l'an prochain ici
les ouvriers voteront pour l'homme qui
sauvera d'abord leur emploi menacé la
raffinerie trop vieille mais qui faisait
vivre sept mille personnes est en effet
condamné facile
nous n'aurons bientôt plus de travail
donc l'histoire des impôts ne nous
concerne pas vraiment notre problème
c'est l'emploi
mais la fontaine continuent de se battre
pour ce qu'il appelle la vérité le
gouvernement de bonn déclare qu'il n'y
aura pas d'augmentation des impôts mais
il faudra bien trouver l'argent quelque
part pour payer la réunification et les
retraites auquel vous avez droit à sa
oskar lafontaine helmut kohl est un
battant avec ces chrétiens démocrates il
est crédité de 46% des voix en allemagne
de l'est pas d'augmentation d'impôts
pour payer la réunification dit il les
deux nouvelles taxes sur l'environnement
seront prélevés ses électeurs fascine et
le froid il faut augmenter les impôts de
toute façon mais ça dépend dans quelle
forme cela prendra ce que dit le
chancelier vrai s'il a dit qu'il n'y
aurait pas d'augmentation d'impôts c'est
qu'il n'y en aura pas
helmut kohl a pu ainsi faire croire aux
allemands que la réunification se ferait
gratuitement à partir de là tous les
espoirs lui sont permis
à la veille de ces élections historiques
la justice allemande vient de délivrer
un mandat d'arrêt contre l'ancien patron
du parti communiste est-allemand erich
honecker accusé d'avoir personnellement
donné l'ordre de tirer sur les allemands
de l'est qui tentaient de fuir leur pays
pour les français vatican rime désormais
avec torrent monseigneur jean louis
tauran 47 ans originaire de bordeaux
vient en effet d'être nommé par jean
paul 2 secrétaires d'état ou saint-siège
autrement dit ministre des affaires
étrangères du pape
il succède à monseigneur casaroli
l'homme de l'ouverture du dialogue avec
l'est
tempête sous un casque ou plutôt sous
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
casques la manifestation organisée par
les sapeurs pompiers aujourd'hui à paris
a réuni en effet plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes bref c'était une
manif sur grande échelle et haute en
couleur rouge bien sûr une broche
calciné restes d'un arbre brûlé cet été
dans le var pour les 220 mille pompiers
en france le symbole d'une profession
peut être bientôt sinistrés neuf
pompiers sur 10 sont des volontaires ils
sont pompiers en plus de leur travail
sans eux pas de secours possibles
or actuellement ils n'ont aucun statut
les sociétés qui nous emploient en tant
que volontaire nous laisse partir
quand il ya le feu ou même pour la
formation pour porter secours sont
offerts des stages pour se former aux
techniques du défendre sur nos congés
nos jours récupérateur les volontaires
demande un statut les professionnels ne
veulent plus du leur il a été conçu un
petit peu sans l'approbation de la
profession en particulier professionnel
qui n'ont pas été concertée au niveau de
ce statut qui a été le passage ce soir
le ministre délégué à la sécurité civile
a fait quelques propositions pour les
pompiers elles sont nettement
insuffisantes
aujourd'hui ils ont manifesté dans un
bruit assourdissant les calmement mais
ils disent commencé à voir rouge
il suffirait d'une étincelle pour que
tout s'embrase dans beaucoup de zones
rurales ou montagneuses le manque de
sapeurs-pompiers pose à terme le
problème de la sécurité même de la
population exemple extrême il est vrai
les hautes-alpes où 99% des pompiers
sont volontaires et où un quart des
casernes est en sous-effectif voir
menacée de fermeture
reportage à n'ourgh clément ce gel ben
je serai prêt est pompier volontaire
mais malgré tout ma profession m'empêche
d'être un pompier volontaire efficace
parce que je suis très souvent absent
parce que comme les autres frédéric ne
peut pas on ne veut pas être pompier la
caserne du village va peut-être fermer
faute de volontaires il en reste six il
en faudrait 40
une fermeture serait grave pour la
sécurité de la population
les secours les plus proches seraient à
trois quarts d'heure de route trois
quarts d'heure en cas d'urgence ces
longs parfois trop long ici le danger
partout avec la forêt et les risques d'
incendies le deltaplane et les nombreux
accidents
les routes sinueuses et très fréquenté
en hiver surtout le maire se bat pour
trouver des volontaires pour éviter la
mort du village
nous risquons également sur le thème le
tourisme d'abord des problèmes parce que
si les gens apprennent qu'il n'y a plus
de centre de se courber la sécurité
n'est plus garantie
gérard est peintre et pompier volontaire
depuis 20 ans à chaque alerte il
quittait son chantier aujourd'hui
parfois les hits une intervention c'est
trois heures donner aux autres 3h02 mois
pour le chantier un choix très dur en
pleine saison quand les interventions
sont nombreuses mais les clients aussi
aujourd'hui beaucoup de volontaires ne
sont pas là ils travaillent trop loin ou
non plus quitter leur poste
interdiction du patron récemment un de
leurs collègues s'est fait licencier il
s'absentait trop souvent
qui travaillé chez moi qui voulais être
pompier
je n'ai pas pu les prendre à cause de ça
parce qu'il ya trop d'interventions qui
se fait et ça on le prend sur notre
temps de travail
mourinho avait quitté paume qui est
parti parce que je pouvais pas le
laisser partir
chaque fois que la sirène sonne et quand
nous appelait donc plus partie de
l'entreprise
cette nuit pour tous les volontaires
entraînements le but remonter une
victime du fond d'un ravin un
entraînement indispensable
complémentaire d'une formation très
poussée
le tout toujours pris sur les temps de
loisirs le soir pendant les week-ends
pendant les vacances pour beaucoup
d'entre eux trop c'est trop
jusqu'ici il travaillait avec leur coeur
quand un de manquer les autres
travailler deux fois plus aujourd'hui
tout se pose une question si rien ne
change dans leurs conditions de travail
qui acceptera encore demain sud allaient
remonter les civières
il est beaucoup plus grave de ne pas
respecter les limitations vitesse que de
voler un autoradio déclaration signée
georges sarre le secrétaire d'état aux
transports n'a pas tort mais ce n'est
pas une raison pour piquer dans les
bagnoles aujourd'hui entrée en vigueur
de nouvelles dispositions importantes du
code de la route
le port de la ceinture de sécurité à
l'arrière et la limitation de vitesse à
50 km heure en ville maryse burgot très
respectueuse du règlement a voulu savoir
si ses concitoyens avaient les mêmes
scrupules
les enfants n'en reviennent pas et les
adultes ont un peu de mal à s'y faire
c'est pourtant la loi la ceinture de
sécurité est obligatoire depuis ce matin
à l'arrière des véhicules
c'est pas facile à leur match longtemps
parce que il en est de même
il a dégrafé quand mon mari viennent
pour la discussion je venais d'étonner
oui je la montre moi je suis entièrement
d'accord
tout à fait je suis moi-même à
survivants d'un statut rouymi 6-4 6-1
accident j'aurais été cuites si je
n'avais pas porté ma station devant les
jeux la mettre derrière deux dérogations
cependant la ceinture à l'arrière n'est
pas obligatoire pour les enfants de
moins de 10 ans pas obligatoire non plus
si le véhicule n'est pas équipé mais si
c'est ceinture existe ne pas les mettre
contre à 230 francs d'amendé il faut
donc s'y faire et résoudre au plus vite
les derniers détails techniques
j'aurais bien voulu la dette mais bon et
ce n'est pas tout vous êtes dorénavant
priés de ne pas rouler au dessus de 50
km ranville les anciens panneaux de
signalisation seront progressivement
changé mais la mesure est effective dès
aujourd'hui 50 km/heure dans toute
personne qui roule au dessus de 51 km
heure sera interceptés et verbalisés
concernant ces deux nouvelles mesures la
police a reçu l'ordre d'être implacable
dès aujourd'hui cette intransigeance
pourrait permettre de sauver quelques
centaines de vies les cotes de
popularité de françois mitterrand et
michel rocard sont toutes deux en net
recul selon le baromètre mensuel sofres
figaro magazine baisse de 7 points je ne
sais plus je suis voilà pour le
président et recule de 6 points pour le
premier ministre de quoi alimenter les
conversations dans les couloirs de la
convention nationale du ps réunie ce
week end à la défense pour élaborer un
projet pour la france de l'an 2000
encore faut-il être pouvoir
à ce moment là reportage roland sicard
et jérôme bastion les socialistes cette
fois avait promis de laisser les
couteaux aux vestiaires il faut dire que
depuis quelques temps et notamment
depuis la sphère des lycéens les
désaccords c'était les oranges des voix
resté prudemment anonyme était même allé
jusqu'à attaquer l'action du président
de la république en personne
une alleyrat suffisamment sérieuse pour
que les responsables du parti remède se
mettre les pendules à l'heure et pour
qu'il soit entendu
françois mitterrand c'est l'unité des
socialistes en 1971
françois mitterrand c'est la victoire de
la gauche en 1981 françois mitterrand
c'est la victoire en 1988 et choisit 11
ans convaincu françois mitterrand sera
un élément déterminant des élections
législatives de 1981 tous unis derrière
le président de la république les
socialistes se sont acheté une conduite
il prépare même leurs projets pour l'an
2000 la synthèse est redevenu à l'ordre
du jour trop synthèse et d'une synthèse
actes il une synthèse dynamique une
synthèse d'imagination une synthèse
création une synthèse qui permet d'agir
pour aller ensemble au devant des
échéances qui sont devant nous
92 93 une synthèse qui nous réunit tous
car ne pas y avoir un parti au travail
est un parti qui soupire désocialise
plein de bonnes intentions décidé pour
une fois à terre leurs différences et à
faire bloc contre la droite
paradoxalement les attaques et contre
attaques des dernières semaines auront
eu pour conséquence de resserrer les
rangs c'est d'ailleurs à cela qu'on
reconnaît les socialistes c'est au plus
fort de la tempête qu'il parvienne à
retrouver leur cap journée mondiale du
sida organisée aujourd'hui par l'om est
sur le thème la femme et sida avec
claudine mulard je vous propose ce
reportage sur une fondation créée aux
états unis par elizabeth glaser l'épousé
de l'acteur qui incarne starsky dans la
célèbre série américaine
cette jeune femme a contacté le virus
lors d'une transfusion sanguine
elle a eu la douleur de perdre sa petite
fille elles mêmes contaminées alors que
son autre enfant et comme elle
séropositifs le courage d'elisabeth
blazer et de sa famille a élu les
américains femme de l'acteur paul blazer
on reconnaît starsky elisabeth a été
contaminé par le virus du sida au cours
d'une transfusion sanguine
après un accouchement sans le savoir
elle a transmis le virus à ses deux
enfants après la mort de sa petite fille
elle a créé une fondation pour les
enfants qui ont le sida
je me suis rendu à washington deux fois
pour rencontrer les membres de notre
gouvernement
j'ai très bien compris que même si leurs
intentions étaient bonnes la
bureaucratie étaient très lentes mais
que moi comme toutes les autres
comme toutes les familles qui se bat
contre le sida une permettre d'attendre
s'il ya des enfants c'est un problème
familial si l'enfant est contaminé c'est
que la famille est contaminée ce qui est
vraiment horrible c'est que comme donc à
vous en a perçu et seulement quand
l'enfant est diagnostiquée faute de
dépistage obligatoire près de 6000
femmes séropositives accouchent chaque
année aux états unis un enfant sur trois
sera contaminée et leur espérance de vie
est d'à peine cinq ans cette mère a été
diagnostiqué trop tard avant ils mènent
ce prix j'ai eu le même petit ami
pendant cinq ans et pourquoi est ce que
je me serai protégé
je ne pensais pas que c'était nécessaire
à l'âge de 4 mois sa petite fille semble
en bonne santé mais les médecins ne se
prononceront définitivement que dans un
an
plus la maladie est avancé chez la mère
plus le risque de contamination est
grave dans ce centre de soins et de
recherche financés par la fondation
d'elisabeth blazer on expérimente des
traitements qui bloquerait la
transmission du virus pendant la
grossesse
la gamme à globuline personnes fournit
des anticorps qu'on peut injecter à la
mer à en bloquer la transmission du
virus
nous essayons aussi de donner un
médicament antiviral l'az était là des
mères séropositives
pendant leur grossesse pour agir contre
le virus
dès ce moment là mais quatre cent mille
enfants de moins de cinq ans sont déjà
contaminés dans le monde
pour eux il faut trouver des médicaments
spécifiques car ils présentent des
symptômes différents comme par exemple
des maladies
bienne ou des complications du système
nerveux central devant l'urgence
elizabeth glaser travaillent sans
relâche à collecter des fonds et à
organiser des campagnes d'information et
de prévention
quand on se trouve dans une situation
comme la mienne et qu'on croit que les
solutions ne sont pas loin car la
plupart des médecins confirme qu'on va
trouver un moyen de soigner et même de
guérir le sida
la question de savoir quand et qui sera
encore là pour en bénéficier
dans cette course contre le sida
elisabeth épaules de lasers ont le
soutien de toute la communauté de
hollywood et surtout du chanteur elton
john un des membres les plus actifs de
la fondation sans une mobilisation de ce
type le sida risque de devenir la cause
majeure de mortalité infantile dans le
monde
précisément le ms estime que d'ici l'an
2000 c'est dans moins de dix ans 10
millions d'enfants de moins de cinq ans
pourraient être infectées par le virus
en cette journée mondiale du sida tous
les médias se mobilisent à travers la
planète
je vous rappelle que faire de riz cuit
terrain y consacrera ce soir son
émission étoiles palace vers 22h30
parmi les très nombreuses initiatives
lancé l'opération red hot n' boulot avec
entre autres la mise en vente au profit
bien sûr de la recherche d'une cassette
de cole porter et d'un disque reprenant
ses plus grands succès succès
interprétés par les artistes les plus
prestigieux parmi lesquels jimmy
somerville annie lennox ou encore si
elle aux chronos clip filmé par les
réalisateurs les plus cotés de la
planète
pierre dux l'un des plus grands acteurs
français de ce siècle est mort
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 82 ans
ce comédien avait interprété les plus
grands rôles du répertoire du
misanthrope à cyrano de bergerac
administrateur général de la comédie
française et directeur de l'odéon pierre
dux avait également fait une très
brillante carrière de metteur en scène
hommage signé marie hélène bono bernard
lebrun une salle debout
à 81 ans pierre dux est consacrée
meilleure comédienne l'année il était
temps par superstition mais par
conséquent je ne peux que vous dire de
bonheur oui 62 ans de carrière de son
vrai nom pierre vargas né en 1908 de
parents tous deux sociétaires à la
comédie-française il les y rejoint dès
1935 pierre dux interprète tout le
répertoire sont chères répertoire de
l'école des femmes au misanthrope de
cyrano à patates
mais le plus grand rôle que ce soir on
lui reconnaît c'est d'abord celui d'un
administrateur général de la comédie
française
il y fut nommé par le général de gaulle
en 45 il y fait le ménage puis s'en va
il reviendra dix ans de 70 à 79
du jamais vu tenez à déranger petit peu
aussi sont son public pour que les
choses avancent
et c'est ainsi qu'avec lui on a pu voir
arrabal ionesco beckett c'était un homme
qui était toujours présent attentif et
pas attentif parce que c'était son
devoir était d'être là mais parce qu'il
aimait être là il joue il est notable
conservateur mais c'était un moderne
on lui doit l'entrée de beckett aux
français et le recrutement d'isabelle
adjani
à 82 ans cette année avec jane birkin il
triompher aux bouffes parisiens donc
quelque part dans cette ville d'euros
vis sa vie c'était là sa niche
quand on a vu l'abordage et qu'on a la
chance de pouvoir encore jouer
physiquement et d'avoir encore une voie
possible est record de la mémoire une
formation bon dieu voilà tout
prémonitoire dans cette pièce arrêté en
octobre pour cause de maladie comme
molière pierre dux mauvais chaque soir
sur scène dans son fauteuil
je recommence
bernard faits sont un témoignage vous
aviez joué avec lui notamment dans z et
jaser nous avions visité quelques jadis
où il portait son panama fait état d' un
homme pour lequel j'avais beaucoup
d'estimé moquer métier et je crois que
des acteurs comme michel robin jane
birkin doivent être aussi triste que moi
ce soir ma façon vous êtes sur ce tabou
sur ce plat tout pardon parce que vous
êtes le héros de nuit américaine lui
africaine décidément vous ne troublait
téléfilm diffusé ce soir sur antenne 2
réalisé par gérard guillaume un téléfilm
qui retrace la vie et l'action d'un
homme pratiquement inconnu du grand
public mais à qui l'on doit de même
d'avoir le premier combattue tout à fait
efficacement un véritable fléau en
afrique la fameuse mooch et c est ce que
nous indique rapidement plus sur ce
personnage que personne ne connaît en
france et keita il reconnu en acier très
très très connue en afrique mais je
crois que le film vous en dira plus et
je pense que le film raconte à la fois
l'histoire d'un homme un homme qui s'est
battu contre une maladie c'est-à-dire sa
passion c'était un chef de bande qui ne
n'acceptait pas les lois normales de la
société de l'administration dont qui
s'est battu à la fois contre la mouche
tsé-tsé contre la maladie et contre
l'administration met en jeu voit que
c'est un film magique sur l'afrique joue
mieux quand voit l'afrique
on est on est on a tourné dans la
brousse en afrique et je crois que les
gens qui aiment le fait que l'afrique
j'avais comme ça vous a pris c'est une
vraie maladie aussi et moi je crois que
j'ai la maladie de l'afrique et la
maladie de la brousse ce docteur
s'appelle eugène jamot il faut quand
même le dire je propose tout de suite de
regarder un court extrait de ce téléfilm
dont qui sera diffusé ce soir sur
antenne 2
je n'osais plus espérer votre visite je
n'arrivais pas à me dépêtrer de leurs
réjouissances stupide faut leur
pardonner toutes les occasions sont
prétextes à divertissement ce sont de
grands enfants vous savez je ne suis pas
venu ici pour m'amuser mais pour essayer
de comprendre à quoi vous jouez à quoi
j'ai joué bien comme vous voyez mon
équipe et moi nous jouons à la chasse au
trépas nos zones c'est follement gaie en
quelques jours sur un mille personnes
visitées nous avons des pistes et 6327
malade c'est à dire 6327 porteurs de
parasites qui peuvent contaminer les
autres et 6327 candidats la mort c'est
une zone yo pa vous plaisantez
non non venez consulter nos registres à
vous entendre le tiers de la population
soit victime de la maladie
je n'ai pas eu cette impression les
voyant ces travaux c'est au son du temps
heureusement il en reste encore
quelques-uns en bonne santé pour
travailler pour payer l'impôt
heureusement et bien voilà donc le dr
jamie grand coeur mais caractère de
cochon c'est vous seul sans même pas un
film plein d'humour
oui je pense donc un très très beau film
et de très très jeune j'ai troqué la
plume très important de
d'autant plus qu'en ce moment la maladie
du sommeil redémarre sur le sida et nous
sommes en plein dans le sujet même temps
c'est un film très beau et quand même
avec des moments drôles
merci nuit africaine donc ce soir vers
vendre et de 50 le livre de léon la
personne et moi j'aime
merci beaucoup à tous derniers mots de
sport avec un petit cocorico et le très
très beau titre de championne du monde
junior de patinage artistique remporté
par surya bonaly 17 ans dans deux
semaines seulement
la patience et la persévérance sont
toujours récompensés sur y avait
remporté la médaille de bronze en 88
l'argent en 89 et cette année enfin vous
le voyez la médaille d'or 20h45 donc
20h50 nous sommes un peu en retard la
nuit africaine
22h30 étoiles palace spécial sida vers
minuit claire chazal pour le tout
dernier journal demain 13h vous
retrouverez hervé claude excellente
soirée merci
dans un instant la météo avec sophie
davant excellente soirée